während paul mit ursula von der leyen
zusammen saß ist noch was anderes
passiert da kam dauern nachrichten rein
von neuen massengräbern und zwar in den
gebieten die die ukrainische armee sich
geradezu zurückgeholt hat von der
russischen armee an massengrab
beispielsweise ist mit 400 leichen
mindestens wir sehen das noch mal auf
der karte wo man das gefunden hatte und
ursula von der leyen hat dann im
gespräch mit ihr noch mal bekräftigt
dass man vladimir putin für seine
kriegsverbrechen zur verantwortung das
hat sie gesagt
dass putin diesen krieg verlieren muss
und für seine taten
einstehen muss das ist mir wichtig
glauben sie dass das jemals passieren
wird das er vor einem gericht
stehen will
ich halte das für möglich
sie hält es für möglich aber deine frage
paul war ja auch wird das jemals
passieren wie schätzt du da sein
statt jetzt wird es nicht passieren denn
dafür müsste wladimir putin gestürzt
werden dafür müsste sein regime gestürzt
werden und auch wenn es dort
innenpolitischen druck gibt in moskau
oder insbesondere aus den regionen ist
es nicht so dass putin dort vor einem
sturz steht also das ist offen
allerdings die geschichte lehrt uns da
nicht auszuschließen und tatsächlich die
dinge für möglich zu halten denn auch
russland kann und wird sich
möglicherweise irgendwann ändern bis
dahin aber muss man mit der situation
weiter machen wie sie momentan ist und
die heißt wladimir putin will
weitermachen mit dem krieg in der
ukraine er ist nicht bereit weitere
truppen abzuziehen und deswegen ist
ursula von der leyen der überzeugung
auch dass es dringend diese kampfpanzer
braucht dann kann uns ein bildreporter
in der ukraine danke an paul ronzheimer
[Musik]